.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE RULES,
IT'S THAT THEY HAVE NO INTENTION
OF FOLLOWING THEM, ANY OF THEM
EVER.
THEY COMMAND YOU TO WEAR A MASK
AS YOU JOG ALONE IN THE PARK
WHILE THEY HEAD TO DINNER
BAREFACED AT THE FRENCH LAUNDRY.
THAT HAPPENED.
THEY FLY TO ASPEN ON THEIR
PRIVATE JETS AND HARANGUE YOU
ABOUT YOUR LAWN MOWER.
HOW MANY HAVE VOTED TO EXPAND
THE POWERS OF THE IRS THAT DON'T
PAY THEIR OWN TAXES?
MORE THAN A FEW.
HOW MANY POLITICIANS WHO SUPPORT
GUN CONTROL FROM ARMED
BODYGUARDS THAT YOU PAY FOR?
EVERY SINGLE ONE.
WHATEVER THEY DEMAND, BE DEAD
CERTAIN THEY'RE NOT DOING IT
THEMSELVES.
IT ENRAGES PEOPLE.
PEOPLE SAY THIS IS HYPOCRISY,
BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S PRIVILEGED.
WHEN NANCY PELOSI WALKS INTO HER
HAIR APPOINTMENT WITHOUT A MASK
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE COVID
LOCKDOWN, NOT BECAUSE SHE FORGOT
TO BRING A MASK, SHE'S AFFIRMING
HER POSITION IN THE SOCIAL
ORDER.
NANCY PELOSI IS IN CHARGE.
YOU ARE NOT.
NANCY PELOSI CAN DO WHATEVER
CARES TO DO.
YOU CAN'T.
ANOTHER WORD FOR THIS IS A CASTE
SYSTEM, INCREASINGLY WHAT WE
HAVE IN THE UNITED STATES.
CASTE SYSTEMS ARE COMMON IN POOR
COUNTRIES, WHERE IMMIGRANTS COME
MOSTLY, BUT IT'S THE OPPOSITE OF
THE TRADITIONAL AMERICAN SYSTEM.
IN THE OLD AMERICA, EVERY 16 WAS
CONSIDERED EQUAL UNDER THE LAW
AS WELL AS THE EYES OF GOD.
EVERYBODY HAD TO FOLLOW THE SAME
RULES BECAUSE NOBODY UNDERNEATH
IT ALL WAS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ANYONE ELSE.
WE WERE ALL CITIZENS.
CITIZENS IS A TERM YOU RARELY
HERE ANYMORE.
CITIZENSHIP IMPLIES INHERENT
RIGHTS, RIGHTS THAT POLITICIANS
CAN'T TAKE FROM YOU, BECAUSE YOU
WERE BORN WITH THEM.
THE PEOPLE RUNNING OUR COUNTRY
DO NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THIS.
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN INHERENT
RIGHTS NOR DO THEY BELIEVE IN
EQUALITY.
YOU MAY REMEMBER HOW HYSTERICAL
THEY BECAME A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WHEN A FEW OLD-FASHIONED SOULS
DARED TO SAY THAT ALL LIVES
MATTER, WHICH THEY CERTAINLY DO.
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE HATED THAT.
THEY DON'T THINK THAT ALL LIVES
MATTER.
IN THEIR VIEW, SOME ANIMALS ARE
MORE EQUAL THAN OTHERS.
IT'S HARD TO THINK OF A NEWS
STORY IN RECENT MEMORY THAT
ILLUSTRATES THIS PHENOMENON AS
CLEARLY AS WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
TWO NIGHTS AGO, GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS GENEROUSLY SENT A
PLANELOAD OF 50 IMMIGRANTS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
IT HAS EVERYTHING YOU COULD WANT
IN THE WORLD EXCEPT FOR RACIAL
DIVERSITY.
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES, THE
RESIDENTS OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD
WOULD HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO SAY,
THANK YOU, GOVERNOR DESANTIS.
YOU MUST ACCEPT THE IMMIGRANTS.
THAT'S THE RULE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW DISRUPTIVE
THESE NEW PEOPLE ARE.
IT'S IRRELEVANT HOW MUCH THEY
COST TO SUPPORT OR HOW
DRAMATICALLY YOUR QUALITY OF
LIFE MAY DECLINE AFTER THEY
ARRIVE, IF THE CRIME RATE
SPIKES, IF YOUR DAUGHTER IS
AFRAID TO GO INSIDE, THE SCHOOL
BECOMES UNUSABLE, THE HOSPITALS
FALL APART, IT DOESN'T MATTER,
YOU TAKE IT LIKE A MAN.
YOU DON'T MENTION IT'S
HAPPENING, EVEN IN PRIVATE TEXT
MESSAGES TO FRIENDS.
IF YOU DO, YOU'RE A DANGEROUS
RACIST, AND COULD WIND UP ON A
GOVERNMENT LIST.
THAT'S HOW AMERICA WORKS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT, BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT'S THE RULE.
BUT IT TURNS OUT THE PEOPLE OF
MARTHA'S VINEYARD ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT MAKE THE RULES.
THEY HAD NO INTENTION OF
FOLLOWING THEM, NOT EVEN FOR A
DAY.
THE VENEZUELANS WERE THRILLED TO
BE THERE.
WATCH.
>> THEY ARE NOT ANGRY AT RON
DESANTIS.
THEY'RE THANKING HIM FOR HAVING
BROUGHT THEM TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
.>> Tucker: WELL, YEAH.
THEY'RE THANKFUL.
THEY GOT A FREE FLIGHT TO THE
VINEYARD.
AT FIRST, IT SEEMED THEY HAD
EVERY REASON TO BE GRATEFUL
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE OF THE TOWN
APPEARED TO WELCOME THEM AS THEY
WALKED IN FROM THE AIRPORT,
3 1/2 MILES, THEY SAW SIGNS LIKE
THIS ONE, ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD,
THE SIGN READS, WE STAND WITH
IMMIGRANTS, WITH REFUGEES, ALL
ARE WELCOME HERE.
HATE HAS NO BUSINESS HERE.
IN OTHER WORDS, NO ONE WORKING
FOR DONALD TRUMP CAN GO TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW THERE WAS A
CAVEAT TO THAT WELCOME.
HATE IS NOT WELCOME HERE.
OKAY.
THEN ON THURSDAY, AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL ON THE ISLAND GAVE THE
MIGRANTS EVEN MORE REASON FOR
HOPE.
AND WE'RE QUOTING.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY RALLYING TO
SUPPORT IMMIGRANT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES, STATE THE STATE
REPRESENTATIVE, DYLAN FERNANDEZ.
IT'S THE BEST OF AMERICA.
THEN TO PROVE HIS POINT THAT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD WILL DO
WHATEVER IT CAN FOR IMMIGRANTS,
FERNANDEZ UPLOADED THIS PICTURE
ON TO SOCIAL MEDIA, BECAUSE, OF
COURSE, EVERYTHING IS A SOCIAL
MEDIA OPPORTUNITY.
THE PICTURE SHOWS SEVERAL
VENEZUELANS GATHERED ON A PORCH,
RUN CELEBRATING RUTH BADER
GINSBURG.
CLEARLY HE GOT THAT FROM A
LOCAL.
ARE THESE PEOPLE WELCOME ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD?
WHAT ARE THEY EATING?
THERE'S NO KALE OR BRIE FOR THE
VENEZUELANS.
INSTEAD THEY GOT CORN POPS,
FROOT LOOPS, RICE KRISPY, WITH A
SIDE AND PAPER NAPKINS.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A NICE PLACE.
THE FOOD IS GARBAGE.
IT'S WAY WORSE WHAT WE EAT IN
CARACAS.
CORN POPS?
FROOT LOOPS?
WHAT MESSAGE ARE YOU SENDING?
HA-HA-HA.
OF COURSE THE MESSAGE IS REALLY
CLEAR MANY THE SERFS EAT
GARBAGE.
WHAT DOES YOUR AVERAGE
VENEZUELAN EAT?
FROOT LOOPS?
VENEZUELANS LOVE FROOT LOOPS.
THEY MAY HAVE GOTTEN THE HINT
THAT THEY WEREN'T REALLY WELCOME
THERE.
IT WAS HARD TO KNOW.
THE COMMUNITY SEEMS TO BE
RALLYING BEHIND THEM.
BUT THEN, IF THERE WAS ANY DOUBT
IN THE MORNING, IT WAS GONE BY
AFTERNOON, BECAUSE THE MESSAGE
CHANGED VERY QUICKLY.
THE NEW MESSAGE WAS, GET THE
HELL OUT OF HERE, BROWN PEOPLE.
>> THE DIFFICULT CHALLENGES ARE
AT SOME POINT THEY HAVE TO MOVE
SOMEWHERE ELSE, RIGHT?
WE CANNOT -- WE DON'T HAVE THE
SERVICES TO TAKE CARE OF 50
IMMIGRANTS.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE HOUSING.
WE'RE IN A HOUSING CRISIS AS WE
ARE ON THIS ISLAND.
WE DON'T -- WE CAN'T HOUSE
EVERYONE HERE THAT LIVES HERE
AND WORKS HERE.
WE DON'T HAVE HOUSING FOR 50
MORE PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T HAVE HOUSING
FOR 50 MORE PEOPLE, SAYS THE
LADY ON AN ISLAND THAT LITERALLY
HAS MORE THAN 100,000 EMPTY BEDS
AT THAT EXACT MOMENT, BECAUSE
IT'S A SEASONAL PLACE.
MORE THAN 100,000 SEASONAL
RESIDENTS ARE GONE.
SO EFFECTIVELY MARTHA'S VINEYARD
WAS THE LARGEST DORMITORY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT NO, THERE'S A HOUSING
CRISIS.
AT SOME POINT THEY'LL HAVE TO
LEAVE, MEANING IN, LIKE, EIGHT
MINUTES MAX.
SO THERE WAS A GUY WHO'S A
LEADER OF A NONPROFIT GROUP, WHO
STEPPED UP TO HELP THE REFUGEES.
HE HAD A DIFFERENT TAKE.
HE SAID THE PROBLEM WASN'T THE
HOUSING AT ALL.
IT WAS THE MIGRANTS.
WE'RE QUOTING NOW.
IT'S LIKE ME TAKING MY TRASH OUT
AND DRIVING TO DIFFERENT AREAS
WHERE I LIVE AND THROWING MY
TRASH THERE, THIS MAN KNOLLED
TOLD NBCNEWS.
OH, THEY'RE TRASH?
THEY'RE HUMAN GARBAGE?
THEY'RE NOT EVEN REAL.
DO THEY HAVE SOULS, VENEZUELANS?
DO REFUGEES HAVE SOULS?
I DON'T KNOW.
THEY'RE LIKE TRASH.
SOMEONE DUMPED THEM ON THE FRONT
LAWN.
GIVE THEM FROOT LOOPS AND GET
THEM OUT OF HERE.
CALL THE TRUCK, HAVE THEM HAULED
AWAY.
NBC NEWS ACTUALLY TWEETED OUT
THAT QUOTE, CALLING OUR BELOVED
SACRED IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY,
THESE NON-DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
TRASH.
ONCE THEY REVEALED HOW THEY REAL
FEEL, THEY DELETED IT A FEW
MOMENTS LATER.
NOT EVERYONE ON THE LEFT, WE
SHOULD TELL YOU, IS SO INTENT ON
SENDING THE MIGRANTS AWAY.
THERE'S THIS ALTERNATIVE.
QUOTE, I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
OBAMAS OPEN UP THEIR HUGE
PROPERTY, PERSPECTIVE TENTS,
LOOK AFTER THESE PEOPLE WHILE
THEY'RE BEING TENTS, SHE SAID.
ACTUALLY WE'RE IN SEARCH OF THE
ONE DECENT LIBERAL LEFT IN
AMERICA.
THAT'S A FAIR POINT.
BARACK OBAMA HAS A LONG
DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF HAVING
PEOPLE ON HIS FRONT LAWN.
IN FACT, HE SET UP A TENT CITY
TO HOUSE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE FOR,
LET'S SEE, OH, HIMSELF, HIS OWN
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
CAN HE DO THAT AGAIN?
OF COURSE.
HE SHOULD.
BECAUSE TO DO ANYTHING LESS THAN
THAT, BARACK OBAMA TOLD US WHAT
ESSENTIALLY PUNISH THE PEOPLE OF
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
MISTREATING IMMIGRANTS WOULD ROB
THEM OF WHAT MAKES AMERICA A
WORTHY COUNTRY.
WATCH THIS.
>> AMERICA IS A NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS.
THAT'S OUR STRENGTH.
AND THE NOTION THAT SOMEHOW WE
WOULD STOP NOW ON WHAT HAS BEEN
A TRADITION OF ATTRACTING TALENT
AND STRIFERS AND DREAMERS FROM
ALL AROUND THE WORLD, THAT WOULD
ROB US OF THE THING THAT IS MOST
SPECIAL ABOUT AMERICA.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
SO IF PEOPLE DON'T CAMP OUT ON
YOUR LAWN, PEOPLE HAVE NO RIGHT
TO BE HERE IN THE FIRST PLACE,
YOU'RE ONLY HURTING YOURSELF.
BUT OBAMA EVEN ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, WHERE APPROXIMATELY
100% OF PEOPLE VOTED FOR HIM AND
LOVE HIM, EVEN ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, HE COULD NOT MAKE THE
SALE.
HE COULD NOT GET PEOPLE TO
THEY TOLD US THIS IS A WAY TO
HELP THE MIGRANTS.
WE'RE QUOTING.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS A COMMUNITY
OF OPEN-HEARTED INDIVIDUALS THAT
VIEW THE MIGRANTS AS PEOPLE, NOT
POLITICAL PAWNS.
OR TRASH.
HA-HA-HA.
HOWEVER, CONTINUING THE QUOTE,
THE ISLAND IS A RESORT COMMUNITY
WITH ONLY 20,000 YEAR-ROUND
RESIDENTS AND ALREADY FACES A
SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OFF-SEASON JOBS.
OH, IT'S NOT JUST RICH ENOUGH.
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH BEDS.
IT'S ONE OF THE RICHEST PLACES
IN THE UNITED STATES, AND HAS
MORE VALUABLE BEDS THAN ANY
OTHER PLACE PROBABLY IN NORTH
AMERICA RIGHT NOW, BUT CAN'T
SWING IT.
YOU CAN DO YOUR PART BY DONATING
TO THE FUND.
BY DONATING TO THE FUND, THEY'LL
HELP THE MIGRANTS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVED IT.
THE FUND RAISED $40,000.
HERE'S THE BEST PART.
YOU'LL LOVE THIS PART.
HOW MUCH OF THE MONEY IS GOING
TO THE MIGRANTS?
OH, NONE.
NONE.
AN UPDATE ON THE FUNDRAISING
PAGE REVEALS THE FUNDS WILL
INSTEAD GO TOWARD, AND WE'RE
QUOTING, BUILDING UP A RESERVE
TO ASSIST SITUATIONS LIKE THIS
IN THE FUTURE RATHER THAN
DIRECTLY HELPING THIS GROUP OF
MIGRANTS IN THEIR SITUATION.
IN OTHER WORDS, MARTHA'S
VINEYARD IS BUILDING ITSELF AN
ENDOWMENT, JUST LIKE HARVARD
IT'S AMAZING.
AN ENDOWMENT FOR MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, NOT TO HELP ANYONE,
BECAUSE WHY WOULDN'T MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WANT AN ENDOWMENT?
OKAY.
WELL, YESTERDAY AT THE REQUEST
OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD
REPRESENTATIVES, THEY BROKE IT
UP.
THE GOVERNOR OF MASSACHUSETTS,
THE THOROUGHLY LOATHSOME CHARLIE
BAKER CALLED UP THE NATIONAL
GUARD.
CHARLIE BAKER, MR. COMPASSION,
LITERALLY BROUGHT IN THE ARMY TO
REMOVE BROWN PEOPLE FROM THE
WHITEST ISLAND IN THE ATLANTIC
OCEAN.
ONCE THE ARMY BROUGHT THEM OFF
MARTHA'S VINEYARD THEY WERE SENT
TO A MILITARY BASE ON CAPE
COD -- A MILITARY BASE?
HOW WELCOMING.
HA-HA-HA.
CAPE COD IS A LOT MORE
REPUBLICAN THAN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
LET'S SEND THEM TO THEM.
HERE'S THE SCENE OF THE MIGRANTS
BEING ESCORTED OUT AFTER LESS
THAN 48 HOURS ON THAT JEWEL IN
THE SEA, MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE, EVERYONE.
WE'RE GOING TO SHOW YOU, AS
WE'RE LEAVING TODAY, A LIVE LOOK
IN MASSACHUSETTS.
WE'RE SHOWING THE FERRY CARRYING
MIGRANTS, WHO HAD BEEN DROPPED
IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD, HAVE
ARRIVED IN CAPE COD.
THAT BUS YOU SEE THERE, HEADING
TO JOINT BASE CAPE COD.
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T MESS
AROUND.
THE LIBERALS AREN'T JOKING.
SO THE REST OF THE COUNTRY, JUST
PICK A CITY, PICK A CITY IN THE
COUNTRY, AND ASK THE PERSON HOW
MANY REFUGEES DO YOU HAVE LIVING
HERE, MIGRANTS, MANY OF THEM
UNDOCUMENTED?
HOW MANY ILLEGAL ALIENS LIVE IN
YOUR CITY AND WHAT DOES IT DO TO
THE SERVICES IN YOUR TOWN?
THEY JUST HAVE TO LIVE WITH IT.
THE HOSPITAL IS A MESS, THE
CRIME RATE IS UP, THE CITY LOOKS
LIKE CRAP.
NOTHING WE CAN DO.
THE GOVERNMENT SENT THEM HERE.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD DON'T PLAY.
THEY BRING IN A ARMY IN A DAY
AND TAKE THEM OUT LIKE THE
GARBAGE.
THERE'S A LOT OF IRONY HERE.
WE'LL TRY TO UNPACK IT AS
QUICKLY AND CRISPLY AS WE CAN,
BUT JUST A DAY AGO WE WERE TOLD
THAT RON DESANTIS WAS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKER, COMPARABLE TO ADOLF
HITLER, BECAUSE HE ORGANIZED THE
TRANSPORTATION OF MIGRANTS IN
HIS STATE TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS SO CRUEL AND SO
UNNECESSARY, SO UNCALLED FOR,
AND SO BRAZEN.
IT SHOCKS THE CONSCIENCE OF ANY
FAIR MINDED HUMAN BEING.
>> THIS TACTIC IS ABOUT AS
UNCHRISTIAN AS IT GETS.
>> STEPHANIE, THAT'S NOT A
POLITICAL STUNT.
IT IS AN ACT OF EVIL, BEING DONE
BY EVIL MEN.
>> SOME POLITICIANS WOULD RATHER
NOT ONLY HAVE AN ISSUE BUT
EXACERBATE IT TO THE EXTENT OF
LITERALLY HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS
YOU SAID.
>> AND SENDING THEM TO
DESTINATIONS BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
OWN THE LIBS.
>> IN A COUNTRY, WHERE A WOMAN
WITH A FETUS INSIDE OF HER, WITH
NO BRAIN, HAS TO TRAVEL A
THOUSAND MILES TO GET AN
ABORTION.
>> LOOK, HERE'S SHORT RON
DESANTIS AND FRANKLY GREG ABBOTT
AND DOUG DUCEY.
WE HATE IMMIGRANTS.
GET THE F OUT.
WE WILL HELP YOU GET THE F OUT.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE.
HA-HA-HA.
MORNING JOE LITERALLY HAD THE
CHIPMUNK ON, TALKING ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH ABORTION, BY
THE WAY.
WHO MENTIONED ABORTION?
I DON'T KNOW.
THESE EXACT SAME PEOPLE ARE
APPLAUDING MASSACHUSETTS FOR
USING THE MILITARY TO REMOVE
UNDESIRABLE IMMIGRANTS, TRASH,
TRASH THEY PROMISED TO SAFEGUARD
TO A MILITARY BASE.
I MEAN, WHAT?
IS ANYONE NOTICING THIS.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT THIS
HAS BEEN GOING ON IN OTHER FORMS
FOR QUITE A WHILE, FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS NOW.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS SENT BUS
LOADS OF PEOPLE TO CHICAGO.
IT GOT SOME ATTENTION.
WE ENJOYED IT.
MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T NOTICE IT.
THE SECOND BROWN PEOPLE ARRIVED
IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD, WHOA,
SWARMS OF REPORTERS DESCENDED ON
THE SCENE BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
THERE BEFORE.
THEY KNOW MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THEY DON'T KNOW A TON ABOUT THE
SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO.
BROWNSVILLE, WHAT?
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, ARE YOU
JOKING?
CNN REPORTED THERE WAS
PANDEMONIUM.
>> THIS IS THE LOCATION.
THIS IS THE ONE HOMELESS SHELTER
THEY HAVE ON THE ENTIRE ISLAND.
THERE ARE FIVE DIFFERENT TOWNS.
ST. ANDREW'S PARISH HOUSE CAN
HANDLE 10.
THEY'VE HAD TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER TO 50 AFTER IMMIGRANTS
WERE UNCEREMONIOUSLY DROPPED OFF
ON TWO DIFFERENT PLANES IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> Tucker: LOOK AT THE GLASSES
ON THAT GUY.
ARE THE GLASSES ON TV PEOPLE
GETTING MORE COMPLEX BY THE DAY?
IN ANY CASE, PUTTING IT IN
PERSPECTIVE BEFORE WE PROCEED,
THIS IS 50 PEOPLE.
50 PEOPLE.
WE'VE HAD 2 MILLION PEOPLE COME
HERE ILLEGALLY.
WHERE DID THEY GO?
THEY WENT TO PROBABLY EVERY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THREW
THEM THERE TO CHANGE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF AMERICA FOREVER.
THAT'S JUST TRUE.
SORRY.
AND NO ONE SAID A WORD.
BUT 50 PEOPLE?
IT'S CHAOS IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
WHY IS ONLY RON DESANTIS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKER FOR DOING THIS?
IT'S INTERESTING.
ACCORDING TO GAVIN NEWSOM HE'S A
KIDNAPPER.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS FLOWN
IMMIGRANTS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY OFTEN THROUGHOUT THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
WE SHOWED YOU FOOTAGE OF THE
FLIGHTS.
THEY'RE HAPPENING IN SECRET.
SECRETLY FLYING PEOPLE AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THE CARTELS DO?
BIDEN IS DOING IT.
BY THE WAY, TO HIS CREDIT, HE
SAID HE WOULD DO IT DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, HE
PROMISED TO RELOCATE MIGRANTS
THROUGHOUT THE U.S.
HE ANNOUNCED THAT THE UNITED
STATES HAS ROOM FOR MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF MIGRANTS.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE CAN AFFORD TO TAKE IN A
HEARTBEAT ANOTHER MILLION
PEOPLE.
THE IDEA THAT A COUNTRY OF
330 MILLION PEOPLE CANNOT ABSORB
PEOPLE IN DESPERATE NEED AND WHO
ARE JUSTIFIABLY FLEEING
OPPRESSION IS ABSOLUTELY
BIZARRE.
ABSOLUTELY BIZARRE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT'S BIZARRE.
YOU'RE A BIGOT IF YOU'RE NOT
INTO IT.
BY THE WAY, JUST FOR
PERSPECTIVE, THE ONE THING THAT
SHOULDN'T BE PARTISAN IS
IMMIGRATION POLICY, BECAUSE
IMMIGRATION POLICY IS THE ONE
POLICY THAT'S IRREPARABLE.
IT CHANGES YOUR COUNTRY FOREVER.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A BROAD
CONSENSUS ABOUT WHAT YOU WANT
YOUR COUNTRY TO BECOME BEFORE
YOU TAMPER WITH THE FORMULA.
SOMEONE LIKE JOE BIDEN, ONLY
PARTISAN, THAT'S IT, DOESN'T
CARE.
BY THE WAY, WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
HE TRANSPORTED ALL THESE PEOPLE
AROUND THE COUNTRY, HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS?
IN ONE COMMUNITY IN FLORIDA,
THAT, QUOTE, CAN AFFORD MORE
MIGRANTS, A 24-YEAR-OLD HONDURAN
MAN MURDERED A FATHER IN HIS OWN
HOME IN JACKSONVILLE.
THAT DIDN'T GET A TON OF
ATTENTION, BUT APPARENTLY PEOPLE
ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD WERE
WATCHING.
THEY DON'T WANT THAT.
THAT'S WHY THE MINUTE BIDEN'S
VOTERS HAVE TO DEAL WITH
VENEZUELANS SEEKING THE AMERICAN
DREAM, THEY CALL IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO SHIP THEM TO MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS, AS FLORIDA'S
GOVERNOR SAID YESTERDAY, THIS
REALLY DOES HAVE TO END.
>> ALL THE PEOPLE IN D.C. AND
NEW YORK WERE BEATING THEIR
CHESTS WHEN TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT,
SAYING THEY WERE SO PROUD TO BE
SANCTUARY JURISDICTIONS, SAYING
HOW BAD IT WAS TO HAVE A SECURE
BORDER.
THE MINUTE EVEN A SMALL FRACTION
OF WHAT THOSE BORDER TOWNS DEAL
WITH EVERY DAY IS BROUGHT TO
THEIR FRONT DOOR THEY ALL OF A
SUDDEN GO BERSERK, AND SO UPSET
THIS IS HAPPENING.
IF YOU HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE
INCLINED TO THINK FLORIDA IS A
GOOD PLACE, OUR MESSAGE TO THEM
WE ARE NOT A SANCTUARY STATE,
AND IT'S BETTER TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO A SANCTUARY JURISDICTION.
YES, WE WILL HELP FACILITATE
THAT TRANSPORT FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO GREENER PASTURES.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
GREENER PASTURES.
ASPEN NEXT.
AND, BY THE WAY, EVERY IVY
LEAGUE COLLEGE, ALL SEVEN OF
THEM, AND THEN MAYBE YOU HIT
WESLEYAN, BODEN AND STANFORD,
THAT SUPPORT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, THAT HAVE MORE
FUNDING PER CAPITA THAN ANY
OTHER INSTITUTION IN THE UNITED
STATES, ELITE LIBERAL ARTS
COLLEGE.
HOW MANY MIGRANTS OR REFUGEES
ARE THEY TAKING?
LET'S HOPE THE GOVERNORS OF SANE
STATES ARE WATCHING HOW
DEMOCRATS HANDLE THIS.
WITHIN 24 HOURS OF HAVING
IMMIGRANTS DUMPED ON THEIR
SHORES, THE PEOPLE OF MARTHA'S
VINEYARD HAD THE MILITARY MOVE
THEM OUT.
WHY IS NOBODY ELSE DOING THAT?
IT'S TRUE.
THERE'S NO LONGER ANY REASON
THAT REPUBLICANS SHOULD DO THAT.
THIS IS THE TEMP